in this video I want to talk about how
transcription ends or how transcription
terminates in prokaryotes specifically
so there are two ways there is ro
independent termination independent
termination which is also called
intrinsic termination and there's Rho
dependent termination Rho is a protein
we'll talk about it shortly but in the
case of Rho independent termination the
Rho protein is not used instead what
happens is a hairpin loop forms due to
these things called inverted repeats in
the DNA and that signals the end of
transcription so if we imagine this
being our DNA strand and RNA polymerase
is going along transcribing RNA
eventually this thing the mRNA itself
loops around itself this thing is the
hairpin loop once that hairpin loop
forms that signals to the RNA polymerase
to stop transcribing and then the RNA
polymerase falls off now this RNA
polymerase is in a prokaryote right so
it must be the core enzyme so how does
this hairpin loop actually form that's
something we'll get to in just a moment
after we talk about an overview of row
dependent termination so if it's row
dependent termination the row protein is
used so what happens the row protein
keep them on this little this thing this
little symbol is the Greek symbol for
row row travels along the RNA transcript
until it reaches RNA polymerase and then
it causes the RNA polymerase
to dissociate from the DNA okay so if we
imagine this to be our DNA strand
this is RNA polymerase it's going
through making RNA then this little ro
protein hops along now Rho is going to
travel along this mo RNA until it
reaches RNA polymerase and when it does
we're gonna cause the RNA polymerase to
fall off dissociate and of course the
real protein itself will fall off so
that is how row dependent termination
works that's pretty much it now let's
talk a little bit more about row
independent termination how this hairpin
loop forms we said that it forms due to
these things called inverted repeats in
DNA so here are details on the inverted
repeats so if this DNA strand is running
five prime to this five prime to three
prime this way and five prime to three
prime this way for the bottom strand
let's imagine this top strand being the
template strand so this here this green
portion is the oh these green portions
rather are the portions in which we have
these things called inverted repeats so
this is an inverted repeat here verted
repeat oops
repeat and over here this is also an
inverted repeat I'll just put inverted
repeat are here okay why is that what
does that mean mean well notice that
here we have g g g c c c g c g now if we
start off from here from here to here
right or actually here we had nine bases
right three g's three C's and a GC G
over here we also have nine and it just
so happens that if you start here it's
going to be compliment
three to two these so here we ended up
with a G here we're starting with the C
so the C is complementary to this G so
if you read this one going this
direction you will find that it's
complementary to these going in this
direction so here we have a C as
complementary to the G a G that's
complementary to the see the see
complementary to this G these three G's
complementary to these three C's and
these three C's complementary to these
three G's so what happens when this
template strand is transcribed into RNA
well this is what we get we get this RNA
strand okay this this strand here is the
RNA and it has these inverted repeats
that are bound by the red lines here and
end written in green so what happens in
what happens here is that the strand
sort of bends and on itself this side
comes in this way and this side kind of
bends in this way and then we have the
loop formation and why is that well
because now this C so I can get a good
color here if I can get this C gonna
hydrogen bond with this G this G is
gonna hydrogen bond with the sea and the
sea will hydrogen bond with this G and
the rest of them are complementary so
they're all going to hydrogen bond so we
have hydrogen bonds here here here here
here here here here and here and that's
gonna hold and this this hairpin loop
together and typically something to note
about this is that usually these are
very GC rich regions why would that make
sense
well GC base pairs have three hydrogen
bonds au base pairs have two hydrogen
bonds so if we want to make sure that
this hairpin loop stays together it
would make sense that the GC root base
pairs kind of make up at least most of
it here I've drawn it all it's not
necessarily gonna be the case I just
wanted to emphasize the point or
exaggerate the point
there could be a you base-pairs in here
so that's how this hairpin loop performs
and once this hairpin loop forms its
signals to the RNA polymerase hey stop
polymerizing we're done here okay and
those are the ways that termination can
occur in prokaryotes
now what about termination of
transcription in eukaryotes look at the
question and the reason why it's a good
question is because this idea is not
really totally understood yet it's not
really well understood how termination
of transcription occurs in eukaryotes so
I'm not going to make a video about it
simply because I don't know and
scientists don't really know too well so
I hope that video was helpful overall
but not disappointing at this little
point here that's about it one last
thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me be my move University at gmail.com
and see the description for more details
thank you for watching